for
e
e e
not yet us
[Music]
hello Christmas happy holidays is there
a weird echo or is it just me okay it's
just me turns out not odd so
announcements after I welcome everybody
again thank you for showing up so happy
to see your faces so happy that you've
chosen to spend this Sunday evening with
us and enjoy your holiday time with us
we know it is um not always easy but we
are glad you are here
um also hello to our online friends who
are watching we're happy you are here
here as well um now
announcement um if you could make sure
you shift to the middle so that people
that come in late today have a place to
sit on the edge without making too much
of a
disturbance and um the next week there
is no service oh no service next week so
we're going to take a break off all
these fine folk will not have to do
anything they will be able to enjoy some
time with their families and then we
will resume on January 5th so mark that
down on your calendars you keep
time and after that let me invite you to
worship the joy of Discovery the moment
when hope and expectation were
gloriously met by the illumination of
one bright star we cannot imagine what
words were spoken by visitors or First
Impressions left them somewhat
confused Messiah savior a King born in
the bearest of places yet they saw and
fell down on their
knees in adoration Lord they saw you and
knew whom they had met as we meet draw
us into the stable in our imagination in
The Quiet Moments of prayer this
Christmas that brief Oasis from the
bustle of the world bring a life to us
the smell of the hay the sound of the
animals The Cry of the baby draw Us
close to our Savior Messiah and King as
we bring not gold myrr or Franken
but the gift of Our Lives the only
offering we can bring
[Music]
amen would you guys stand with us as we
sing Carol's
tonight come come Manu
and Ransom captive
[Music]
is that MNS in lonely
Exile until the Son of
God
appear
Rejoice rejoice
uel shall come to the
[Music]
oh oh come desire of
Nations oh people in one
heart and mind
did every sad
division
SE and fill the world with the heaven PE
sing
Rejoice
REO
[Music]
Rejoice
you shall come to the oh we
is
Rejoice
uel shall come to the
[Music]
oh
hej hej
[Music]
you shall come to me oh
he right here
[Music]
Oh Holy
Night the stars are brightly shine
it is the night of our
dear's
[Music]
birth lay the
world in sin
anding till he
appears and the Soul felt it
wor a thrill of Hope
a thrill of
Hope the wey World
Rejoice
we
prise a new and
[Music]
glorious on
your oh he
the angel
voice
oh
Divine
ohy
God
oh divine
oh
night oh
mighty
Tru he taught us to love one
another his
is and his
goel
[Music]
is chain shall he
PR for the slave is our
brother and in his name all
oppression shall
see sweet HS of
joy in grateful chorous prise we let all
within us praise His Holy
Name
all on your
knees oh
here the
angel oh
night
div know
[Music]
when Christ was
born oh
[Music]
night
divine no
night oh night
divine Christ
CHR is the Lord
Oh
Praise His Name
[Music]
forever his
plan and
[Music]
glory for more
Proclaim
oh on your knes
oh
here the angel
voice
night
de oh
night when Christ was
born oh night
[Music]
Divine oh
night oh nighty
[Music]
in those days Caesar Augustus Augustus
issued a decree that a sensus should be
taken of the entire Roman world this was
the first sensus that took place while
querias was governor of Syria and
everyone went to their town to
registrate so Joseph also went up from
the town of Nazareth and gallery Gile to
Judea to Bethlehem the town of David
because he belonged to the house and
line of David he went there to
registrate with Mary who was pledged to
be married to him and was expecting a
child while they were there the time
came for the baby to be born and she
gave birth to her first born a son she
wrapped him in cloths and placed him in
a Manger because there were no guest
rooms available for them and there were
shepherds living out in the fields
nearby keeping watch over their flocks
tonight an angel appeared to them and
the glory of the Lord Shone around them
and they were terrified but the angel
said to themo not be afraid I bring you
good news that will cause great joy for
all the people today David a savior has
been born to you he is the Messiah the
Lord this will be a sign to you you will
find baby wrapped in cloths and lying in
a Manger suddenly a great company of
heavenly hosts appeared with the angel
praising God and saying glory to God in
the highest heavens and on Earth peace
to those whom his favor rest when the
angel had left and gone into heaven the
Shepherds said to one another let's go
to bethle him see this thing that has
happened which the Lord has told us
about so they hurried off found Mary and
Joseph and the baby was lying in a
Manger when they had seen him they
spread the word
concerning what had been told to them
about this Tri and all who heard it were
amazed at what the shepherd said to
them HK the head ruled Angels see
glory to the
newborn
king peace on Earth and
mercy
my God and sin is
[Music]
reconcile
joyful oh ye
nations
rise join the tribe
of the
SK with
Angelic H
Proclaim Christ is born in
bethle heart the
heral Angels
Sing glory to the newborn
glory to the
new glory to the newn
[Music]
king Christ by
highest
theore Christ the ever
Everlasting
Lord made in time Behold Him
come
offspring of the
[Music]
virgins flesh the god
se heav
incar
de
pleas men with men to
dwell Jesus
you
will the
heral Angels
Sing glory to the
newborn
king
glor glory to the new king
[Music]
the heav born Prince of
Peace have the son of
[Music]
rightousness light and Life to all he
BRS risen with
healing in
his M he lays his glory
[Music]
for
that no more may
die Born to Raise the sons
of Born to give them
second
birth part the
ha Angels
Sing Glory
to the
newn
king glory to the new
[Music]
king glory to the new king
glor glory to the newb King
shout
it go on and scream it from the
mountain go on and tell it to the
masses that he
is
[Music]
God Shout
go on and scream it from the
mountain go on and tell it to the
m that he
is
[Music]
God sing out go on and screaming the
cry
out see
our
[Music]
God sing
out
on cry out
[Applause]
tell Sing
[Music]
Out go on and scream it from the
mountain go on and tell it to the Man
[Music]
that he
is God sing that one more time just
[Music]
poises go on and scream it
the go
on it the
that he is
[Music]
God yes tonight we celebrate that you
are The God Who is with
us
Emmanuel that you stepped into our
world and became one of
us and you have breathed divinity into
our
lives you have rescued us from
Darkness you are the light of our
world would we follow that light Jesus
this Christmas
season in your name
amen would you guys welcome the people
around you and would you also join me in
giving Addie Pierce a hand as she was
our reader tonight and did such a great
job thank you
[Applause]
Addie are we all coming up
well merry
Christmas and
uh Merry Christmas to you all and
welcome it's a joy a joy to be with you
and uh yeah to have you in this space my
name is Brett and I'm the pastor here um
and yeah it's just a beautiful time
together and I'm so so grateful um to be
with you
and just welcome you into the space and
as always that includes uh those joining
us online and Merry Christmas to you all
there and don't forget to get a little
candle or something for later in the
service we'd love for you to be able to
join us in that and also want to extend
a warm welcome to anyone here tonight
who is new um maybe it's your first time
or just first time in a long time and uh
we're really really glad that you're
here um yeah we want you to know that we
just really hope you kind of receive or
experience a god of Welcome a Christ of
compassion and uh just a hospitable
Community uh here at the table so uh the
title of my message uh this Christmas is
open open and our Christmas story was of
course read so beautifully um by Addie
Pierce I'm not going to go back and like
reread you know all of Luke Chapter 2
instead I just want to focus in on uh
just two vers vers verses 10 and uh 11
in that story and it reads but the angel
said to the Shepherds do not be afraid
for I bring you good news that will
cause great joy for all the people today
in the town of David a savior has been
born to you he is the
Messiah the
Lord so it's it's really only
now that I like truly truly
appreciate the act of
holding a little newborn baby uh back
when maybe it's I'm getting old and
sentimental I don't know but back in
like my mid 20s when my wife and I were
having all the babies and doing all that
stuff um well she was having the babies
and I was helping raise them um it was I
appreciate you I mean I love of course I
love my kids and the my C their little
fingers and toes and all it's like
incredible um and to see these little
beans you like grow up it's incredible
but there's just something like I was I
was missing some maybe it's more that
I've changed that um like kind of the
what I've kind of been reflecting on you
know like why is it that like now like
when I hold the little one I'm just like
oh my gosh like what a miracle this is
like it's almost like an angel or
something you know like I cannot believe
it now not when they're up at like 3:00
a.m. like a okay that's not that's tough
but like when they're there and just so
vulnerable there just something so
incredibly like touching and beautiful
about it and it's like every year that
passes I just appreciate it more and
more and so I've been you know thinking
like what is it like is it am am I
changing like what is what's going on
why why is it so different for me now
and I think what's happening uh it's
something similar that's happened to me
in weddings now uh like when I attend a
wedding it's so much more meaningful and
I think the perspective is like in
essence I have suffered more and I've
seen sort of what life does to people
like over time like how incredibly hard
and difficult it can be so like in the
same way when I'm there like say a
wedding I see these you know especially
when they're younger you know in their
early 20s you can tell they have no clue
you know they have no idea what's coming
like oh and now I'm just like oh my gosh
like look at them look at them like
they're so full of Faith you know like
so full of sort of a sense of optimism
and like the world's before them and
there's something similar when I'm
holding a newborn that it's like I like
I'm holding this little
being who still
trusts who still is just like
open just just open open to to
whoever is there like the developmental
psychologists say it's usually around
like month seven or so that little you
know newborns um I mean they know who
Mama and Daddy are like pretty quick but
they they'll start to get maybe a little
more rejection in me you know or kind of
they'll that's not a word but they'll
they'll be more stand offish to like new
ones you know like you're like oh here
me hold the baby and they're like no you
know so that happens around like month
you know six seven eight somewhere in
there but of course a newborn right
especially when you're talking like
weeks
months I mean there's none of that right
they're just like open to
whoever and and that's why like as you
hold them it's like you're well they
melt like Wax against your body you know
they're so warm and just cuddly in and
you melt right along with
them today in the town of David a savior
has been
born just imagine that like God in
Christ is
born born naked born crying born
vulnerable open open open to whoever and
whatever may come I just think of his
life open open to the to the
demon-possessed person kind of frothing
at the mouth like open to the lepers
with their missing fingers and
toes open to the sweetness and goodness
of Friendship with Martha Mary Lazarus
open to whole nights spent in prayer
feet asleep from bowing low open to
Miracles flowing from his fingertips
open to being able to do no miracles in
his hometown the one place that if I
were him that's exactly where I'd want
to be able to do Miracles you know open
to his little band of disciples
knowing they would like never understand
half of what he's
saying until he's left this body open to
the little
flowers that just Blossom up and then
tomorrow Fade Away open to the birds of
the air who never store up anything and
yet are always provided
for open to betrayal by the kiss of a
friend open to the humiliation of the
Cross open to Resurrection and
Ascension open open open and I think
this is why Christ was able to the kind
of draw out so much love in people and
in in many ways that I mean that still
continues like people see in
him uh someone vulnerable like he didn't
just drop from the heavens fully formed
like some Angel demanding like hey I'm
awesome worship me and like none of that
instead he came like I mean look at how
he was born not not only born but then
where in poverty in a Manger like the
lowest of the lowest of the low just
open look at how he lived with no place
to lay his
head and look at how he died arms spread
wide on a cross just
open and I think this is why people feel
like they can commune with him they can
grasp him they can connect
with
him and and that's a very different
thing than saying you know something
like um like hey look at how people
respect him I mean like certainly
there's there's plenty to respect about
Jesus he was he was a great public
speaker he had lots of Charisma um he
was very kind of holy and right like
lived
well you know so there plenty to respect
about him but you know like ultimately
it was what was it about him it was his
childlike
vulnerability and his
love that just
aroused a certain connection with
others see God in Christ is born he's
born naked he's born crying he's born
vulnerable open open open to whoever and
whatever May Come
and so it is with
us you see we might be tempted to
say like you know I'm so glad that
Christ was that way it is so wonderful
of him and I do I feel like I can with
him and it's like great for him uh but
of course the
invitation is what for us it's to live
in the same way right that same kind of
heart posture that same kind of O
openness I mean it's no coincidence that
he told his
followers that if you want to enter the
kingdom of heaven right in other words
if you want to live every moment just
saturated by the love and the presence
of God who are you going to have to be
like what did he say you're going to
have to become like a child
again which is maybe a little offensive
to like uh we're adults you know or
something but and and what was he
getting at with that you know did did he
mean we we need to become immature again
or something like no I think instead
what he he meant was we need to become
openhearted
again friends this
Christmas this coming
year be
openhearted
again be vulnerable willing even to
being hurt by that I don't mean that
that we kind of open ourselves to
Perpetual chronic abuse or something you
know perpetuate others wrongdoings I
don't mean that but but I mean that we
we take the risk of openness and honesty
and transparency and that and and what
what do we do when that
happens well suddenly the love of God
begins to flow in our life
again I think uh the classic Christmas
movie that highlights all this
beautifully is I mean it's sort of a
recent classic but I think I think it
deserves the status is
elf which is it is awesome I remember
the first time I watched this I was like
what is going on I like didn't know like
is this funny but the more I watch it
I'm like oh my gosh this is hilarious
and uh of course you've seen the film
you know buddy the Elf played by will
phell get the picture and um he's I mean
in the film he's just childlike to the
core you like yes to a fault he is sort
of the other side of child you know he
is kind of immature and and all that um
but like on the good side he's just
completely open with everyone he's just
like Hello World here I am I love you
all you know he just expects to give and
receive love and what's crazy about it
is it happens right because people are
struck by he's almost a holy fool in a
way you know where there's this this
kind of openness that even if people
don't intend for it to happen it kind of
it begins to um just open them
up oh yeah this is all I I do love this
service every year I must admit because
um I'm so grateful for children and I
mean that like there's a lot of churches
who would oh would kill to have some
little ones around so I say don't you
worry about it Dad it's good you got it
Zach um so yeah there's now you know the
plot of the film though kind of um is
really driven by the relationship that
buddy has with his
father um Walter Hobs oh it's
intense little baby see the newborns are
so vulnerable and little and it gets it
gets a little tougher it does admittedly
it gets tough um so Walter H you've seen
the film you know this is his buddy's
dad and uh he's basically the opposite
of buddy I think it's supposed to be
kind of a
symbol of us uh like adults right cuz he
is overworked he's freaking stressed out
he's quite cold-hearted emotionally very
shut down probably could use some
therapy you know it's like hey buddy
open up a little and and so buddy kind
of enters his life like some sort of
wrecking ball you know just like what
this is my son you know and so that's
kind of the plot of the film right is in
essence um buddy well there's that
moment where buddy finds out from Santa
uh that not surprisingly his dad is on
the naughty list y'all remember this
moment when will Pharaoh plays it up so
good he's just like no like he's just
freaking out you know and why is that
because he knows his dad needs to be
saved you know like in essence like he's
he he he needs a certain openness he
needs that childlike Wonder again he he
needs to um recover what we all start
out with
and this is why Jesus says You must
become like Buddy the elf again you know
this is why it's because we do right we
start off in a very different place as
children now for some of us childhood
was rough right so it could have changed
quickly but going back to that newborn
right we all start in this
place just
open
open open to whoever and whatever May
Come and there is a beauty in that but
at some point so many of us right life
is hard and it just grinds us down and
we say you know what I'm just not taking
that risk
again I'm just not I'm not going to do
it and what do we do it's like our our
hearts
become like a wall a mile high
and we're cordial with people you know
we even give them a little bit so they
think that we're really opening up for
something you know enough that they're
like oh yeah they're a good person you
know but we do we the downside of that
though is we start to feel isolated and
distant we can be around people but we
feel alone what are we missing we're
missing that that openness
again and so this is what happens right
pain comes along I mean sometimes it's
just simply we kind of live with that
openness and then someone shuts us down
and they're like whoa big feelings there
and I'm not open I'm not up for that you
know or maybe it was some sort of um
deeply difficult
experience that you processed in
aloneness and it it kind of turned into
this trauma in your
life it's different for all of us but
but what happens because that we start
to shut down and then Love Is On Life's
support in our Rel
relationships you see friends love
flourishes in a life that is
open and
undefended love flourishes in a life
that is open and
undefended what that really looks like I
think on a day-to-day basis is a posture
of
Welcome welcoming life open open open to
whoever and whatever ever may come
people feelings
experiences you say oh
okay I'm up for it God is me and you
here we go there's something so
incredibly
Courageous about living as Christ did
just
open there's a uh a story that Catholic
Theologian and fr Richard Roar tells and
this was as a I think it was as a child
in his younger years he lived next to a
Native American woman and she had this I
don't know if it was like a spiritual
practice or just kind of a ritual
probably the the lines there are kind of
hazy you know sort of all of it and she
had this ritual what she would do is um
she would stand on her back
patio and it faced to the East and she
would rise early like Before Dawn and
she would stand there in the
dark and she would rotate her
hands like
this and slowly but
surely the Sun would
rise and she would just stand there just
welcoming the light almost willing it to
be
so
friends like that's a picture of how
Christ invites us to live
welcoming the day welcoming the year
open to whatever may come so the
invitation this evening I think is
really twofold and I'll close with this
there are some of us here tonight
and it's the openness has kind of shut
down so to speak between us and God you
know like it could be because we grew up
in a certain like religious environment
with really kind of toxic theology that
that beat us down told us we were trash
you know whatever whatever it looked
like but it wasn't really a message
about the love and grace and goodness of
God and because of that we've grown very
distrustful and distant our hearts are
closed off and so the invitation for for
you would be this coming year open
yourself up to the love of God again
like open yourself up take that risk the
risk of prayer the risk of scripture the
the risk of church and worship and and
en joying and participating again so
that's the first group the second group
it's not so much with you and God it is
it's it's with you and
others right there's a a shutdown a
closed down you're living very defended
and God's invitation to you is be
openhearted
again and I just I I imagine what could
happen if one year from this day we're
back we're gathered for another
Christmas service and like what could
change in your life if you would live in
that way like I I I just I know God
would meet you God would meet you and I
wonder what God could do in our
community if like all all of us together
started to live in this way man I it
would be a beautiful beautiful thing so
that's the invitation this Christmas
let's live open open open open in the
name of the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit
amen so when you sat down there was a
candle on your seat and I want to invite
you to go ahead and grab that and in
just a moment we'll uh start the candle
lighting process but um just so you know
the way it will work darl's going to
come and he's going to kind of start the
the lighting up here on the front and uh
we're just going to kind of turn to our
neighbor and pass the light what I would
ask is if your candle is already lit
that you not be the one to turn it to
the side to you know because then the
wax strips off gets over everything so
if your candle is not lit you be the one
to turn it to the side um also if you're
joining us online I would love for you
to participate go grab a candle from the
house and and uh yeah join us at this
time so
tonight here at the table the season of
Advent the longing for the arrival of
God and Christ in the world comes to an
end and Christmas
begins so as this light begins to spread
may it be may it be a symbol may it be a
a picture of the love of God in Christ
flowing
from you to your neighbor to our
community and from us to the whole world
Merry Christmas
Oh
Come Oh Ye
Faithful
joyful and
Triant Oh
Come Ye
come me to
be
the
come and
Behold Him B the king of
angels oh come let us
adore oh oh come let us
adore oh come let us
adore in
Christ for you
alone are
worthy for for you alone are
worthy for you
[Music]
are
Christ would you stand us
as we give you all the
glory we give give you all the
[Music]
glory we'll give you all the
GL
we
[Music]
cist oh come let us
adore Oh Come
[Music]
us us
adore Christ
[Music]
thank you so much for joining us this
evening you can go ahead and blow out
your candle please do not set them on
your seat or on the ground because hot
wax will drip um instead on your way out
you can hand them to an usher at the
door um if you were new we would love
for you to fill out a card at our tiny
table or just scan the QR on the screen
QR code on the screens and fill out the
online visitor card um that will allow
us to follow up with you answer
questions any questions you might have
and say thank you for visiting thank
you um don't forget next week no
Services we'll resume on January 5th um
and you won't want to miss it as we
start story Sundays um and then um let
me leave you with with this benediction
as we go into the
holiday so um if you can put your hands
out in a posture to receive or just open
your heart to these
[Music]
words may you be filled with the Wonder
of
Mary The Obedience of Joseph the joy of
the Angels the eagerness of the
Shepherds the determination of the Magi
and the glory of the Christ and may you
live open open open to all that God has
for you in the coming days face go in
peace and have a merry Christmas you are
dismissed Oh Come All Ye
[Music]
Faithful
joyful and
trium Oh
Come Oh
Come you
[Music]
come and be